Opens up a whole can a very,
very interesting issues.
This try and pick a couple of them,
but the [inaudible] hard to,
it's evident to me,
and I'm enormously encouraged by this
because I,
you know,
I'm a passionate Australia and I'd want
this country to be the sort of place
that offers opportunities of the sort
that I had when I was young.
You know,
I've had my opportunities when I look at
my kids' generation,
what's going to be there for them if we
keep feeding them the sort of thin grew
in reality,
the people turning out in vast numbers.
Every one of your talks in Australia's
been oversubscribed massively.
It tells you they kind of get those more
to this.
They're being tall.
Oh
yeah.
They know well.
It's one of the things that's so
interesting about dealing with
archetipal themes.
You know archetipal themes are
archetipal because they actually speak
of the structure of human experience.
That's why they last.
And so it's human nature and human
experience has a pattern.
You don't have the capacity to do
articulate that pattern as an individual
in part because your life is too short.
You just can't figure it out.
But the,
the ancient representations of those
patterns are everywhere around you and
you,
you know,
some of them in the image,
you,
you caught onto them automatically,
you fall into them.
If you go to a movie,
for example,
because movies always expressed
archetipal themes.
If you hear them articulate it,
you think,
I,
I knew that.
I just didn't know how to say it.
That's,
that's the platonic idea of,
of,
uh,
of learning as remembering your,
your soul already knows,
but it doesn't have the words.
And so when people talk to me about
watching my lectures,
let's say they say,
they basically say one of two things.
If it,
if it's not just a simple thank you.
They say one of two things.
A third of them say,
quarter of them say,
when I listen to you talk,
it's as if you're telling me things that
I already know.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's exactly right because that's
what archetipal stories are there.
The description of what you already
know,
but that can be articulated.
And then who you are and how you see
yourself and the way you described
yourself all become the same thing.
So that's wonderful.
Then you're not at odds with yourself,
you know,
and then you have,
then you're a functioning unity and that
makes you much stronger and more
indomitable than you would otherwise be.
And then the other thing that people
say,
and this is more like three quarters of
them,
is that they say,
I was in a very dark place.
I was addicted,
I was,
I was drinking too much.
I had a fragmented relationship with my
fiance and I wasn't getting married.
Uh,
things weren't going very well with my
family.
My relationship with my father was
damaged.
I didn't have any AME.
I was wasting my time.
Some variant of that,
some combination of those.
And they say,
well,
I've been watching your lectures.
I've decided to establish a purpose.
I'm trying to tell the truth and things
are way better.
And I've,
and so let's say I've done maybe eight
or nine large scale public talks in the
last two months.
So that's probably 20,000 and about half
of them a third to half of the misstate
afterwards to talk to me.
So that's about 7,000 people who have
said that to me.
And then people stop me on the street
all the time.
And tell me exactly that story,
which is just wonderful.
Like you can't imagine how good it is to
be able to go to places you've never
been.
And to have people start peeling the
streets spontaneously and say,
look,
my life is way better than it was.
It's like,
it's so good.
And so,
and I've got like,
I dunno,
35,000 letters from people since last
August.
It's more than that.
I can't keep track of them.
And it's exactly the same thing,
like three quarter quarter of them say,
well,
you've given me the words to say what I
already knew was true.
And thank you for that.
I can see that in the audience.
It's so interesting because I can lay
out a story.
People go like this and say they're
doing that all the time.
It's like the lights are going on.
And that's a really,
while there's no,
almost nothing better than that to watch
lights go on when you're talking to
people,
it's like that's just absolutely
fantastic.
But to get this response from people,
my father,
I haven't,
my father is about 80,
80 is 83,
I think.
[inaudible] 81,
he's 81.
And uh,
I put it in charge of,
of going through my viewer email,
um,
which is an overwhelming job.
But now we've had discussions about this
constantly.
He's overwhelmed by the fact that so
many people are writing and saying the
same thing.
It's like,
well,
I have a purpose in my life actually
matters.
I finally realized that and I'm putting
it into practice and I'm bearing up
under the heaviest load I can imagine.
And it's really helping.
It's like God,
and that's tens of thousands of
responses now.
So it's,
it's,
you couldn't hope for anything better
than that.
There's zero harm in it,
right?
It's just people putting their lives
together,
they're not mucking about with other
people and are trying to make broad
scale social transformations about which
they have no idea.
They're trying to make their immediate
environment better and it's working.
It's like great,
great.
You say the zero harm in it,
say as a former legislator that there's
an enormous amount of good at a country
is only the,
some title of the people that make it up
to the extent that they put together
resilient.
I only contribute,
don't have to ask others to help them.
The stronger the nation and rapidly like
I,
I mean I think I was thinking the other
day some a journalist asked me why the
audience,
why people are responding so positively
to what I'm saying,
the young men for example,
and I thought,
hmm,
why?
Why?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
He says,
well,
I'm actually on their side.
I'm pretty happy that I'm really happy
that they're not wasting their lives.
I'm really sad to see that people are
disenchanted and nihilistic and
depressed and anxious and aimless and
and perverse and vengeful and,
and all of those things.
It's terrible.
And then to see people question whether
that's necessary and then to start to
rise out of that,
it's like,
it's so fun.
Like last night I was at after my talk.
It's overwhelming.
I don't usually think about these
things,
but I was,
I was after my talk last night,
didn't.
So all these people line up and you
know,
they have their fifteens 15 seconds with
me and they're kind of tentative.
They're excited in a tentative,
when they come up to talk to me and then
they have,
you know,
15 seconds of time to tell me something.
I'm really listening to them and they're
hesitant about whether or not to share
the good news about their life.
You know?
And I think it's often because
okay,
when people share good news about their
life,
people don't necessarily respond
positively.
You know,
they don't get encouragement and people
need so little encouragement.
It's just unbelievable.
And so they'll tell me something good
and I think,
God,
that's so good.
You know,
somebody says,
oh,
I'm getting along way better with my
father.
I haven't seen him for 10 years and now
we get along.
It's like crate.
And then the power of that,
you can't overstate the power of that
for individuals to get their life
together.
They individuals an unbelievably
powerful force.
And every single person who gets their
act together a little bit has the
capacity to spread that around them.
It's,
it's a chain reaction.
And so it's a lovely thing to see and
that's fantastic.